les migrations 3è partie aujourd'hui les
migrations
intérieures à la base de ces exposé
numérique le dictionnaire de géographie
des éditions hâtiers l' migration
intérieure c'est quelque chose qui est
quand même assez difficile à étudier
parce que il y a une diversité
importante de mouvements qui va lier un
grand nombre de personnes qui ne sont
pas toujours répertorié ou inventorié
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une difficulté de
recensement desmigration intérieure
évidemment vous vous pouvez changer de
domicile ça va être très difficile un
certain moment de savoir est-ce que vous
le faites de manière définitive ou pas
est-ce que c'est une résidence
secondaire donc vous comprenez là il y a
une difficulté au niveau
comptable un des premiers mouvements
qu'on va inventorier dans ces migration
intérieure c'est l'exode rural vous
savez tous ce qu'est l'exode rural c'est
la migration de la population rurale
vers les centres urbains autrem dit les
gens quittent les campagnes pour
rejoindre les
villes cet exode rural est tout toujours
lié à la révolution industrielle au
développement un certain moment de
l'économie et de la société on va donc
voir apparaître l'exode rural tout
d'abord au 19 au 18e siècle pardon à la
fin du 18e siècle en Angleterre puisque
c'est là que la révolution industrielle
apparaît aussi en premier au 19e et au
20e siècle cet exode rural va se
poursuivre notamment dans les pays dit
développés ou industrialisé c'est-à-dire
l'Europe l'Amérique du Nord et euh
au 20e et au 21e siècle donc toujours
actuellement cet exode rural se poursuit
dans les pays en voie de développement
les pays asiatiques africains voire
sud-américain évidemment avec comme
conséquence l'explosion de la population
citadine et l'apparition de grandes
métropoles à l'échelle mondiale avec des
villes de plus de 20 million
d'habitants l'exode rural peut être
éventuellement contrôl alors c'était le
cas en Chine avec le uku ce petit livret
de résidence qui devait contrôler les
déplacements de la population
c'est-à-dire que vous ne pouviez pas
quitter votre région sans avoir une
autorisation préalable et de ce fait la
mobilité de la population était
relativement limitée et donc l'exode
rural lui aussi
l'était ce cette politique de contrôle a
été nettement assouplie depuis quelques
années je vous demande alors à ce
moment-là si vousz si vous voulez en en
savoir plus de retourner dans la
séquence de cours consacrée à la Chine
vous avez des documents qui traitent en
particulier de cette
problématique l'exode rural on a donc un
phénomène très complexe parce que à cet
exode rural qui est quand même
relativement simple à comprendre on va
avoir d'autres mouvements qui vont venir
se greffer comme les mouvements
interurbains le fait que certaines
personnes quittent une ville pour une
autre la réurbanisation qui est en fait
l'Urban ationtion des campagnes on
connaît très bien ça en Belgique quand
vous sortirez de la Berlière en
direction de mveau vous regarderez ces
petites maisons qui sont construites un
peu partout au sein de la campagne c'est
ça la réurbanisation de la campagne on a
aussi des rétromigrations c'està-dire
des gens qui font marcher arrière qui
décident un certain de revenir à la
campagne et donc il y a de multiples
combinaisons qui complexifient le
phénomène on va avoir l'opposition entre
deux types de migration à côté de cet
exote rural c'est les migration tion
interurbaine et les migrations
intraurbaines donc ici on ne parle plus
des campagnes mais on va parler plutôt
des mouvements qui se font d'une ville à
l'autre alors les migration
interurbaines c'est les migration entre
des villes généralement on quitte une
ville une petite ville ou une ville
moyenne vers une ville d'importance
régionale voire nationale imaginons
quelqu'un qui habite hat qui est une
petite ville pour tourner bah là il y a
il quitte une petite ville pour une
ville plus importante au niveau régional
ou alors qu' quitte h pour Bruxelles et
là il quitte sa ville pour une métropole
nationale pourquoi est-ce qu'on quitte
sa ville bien souvent c'est motivé par
une recherche d'emploi on a des
qualifications qui ne permettent pas de
trouver un emploi là où on est donc on
va se on va bouger pour justement faire
valoir ses compétences ça peut être
aussi la recherche de services qui ne
sont pas présents dans une plus petite
ville donc il s'agit souvent d'une
population jeune les migration
interurbaine ça c'est souvent des des
jeunes qui qui effectuent ces mouvements
là les migration
inurbaine là on a un mouvement en fait
qui est centrifuge donc on va voir des
personnes qui vont quitter les centres
villees mais toujours pour rester dans
cette villeel mais plutôt pour aller en
périphérie de la ville dans la banlieue
pourquoi parce que peut-être qu'il y a
un cadre de vie plus intéressant avec un
jardin avec plus un style de vie
campagnère
alors sur une carte ben on va
directement observer ici des mouvements
comme ça interurbains donc des gens
quittent des zones urbanisées vers des
centres
euh régionaux ou nationaux donc ça peut
aussi être le cas en en Flandre pardon
où des gens comme des Louvanistes vont
quitter Bruxelles vont quitter Louvin
pour bruelles ou pour enverse alors bien
sûr dans le Limbourg on va avoir un
mouvement comme ceci voire même des gens
qui vont passer la frontière
linguistique et bon dans les zones peu
urbanisées comme le Luxembourg là les
mouvements seront plus importants
évidemment les migration intraurbaines
donc dans le cadre d'une ville ici vous
avez la ville de Paris avec le
centre de Paris voilà la tourelle doit
être ici quelque part et donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe ben les individus pour
plusieurs raisons notamment parce que
les loyers sont hors de prix vont
quitter les centres en direction des
périphéries alors ça peut être une
raison économique mais ça peut être
aussi une recherche d'un meilleur cadre
de vie quoi que dans le cas parisien ça
ne marche pas donc ici on a un mouvement
centrifuge du centre vers la périphérie
donc qui fuit le centre centrifuge ou
alors on aura aussi mais dans une
moindre mesure des mouvements centripèes
avec des gens qui vont revenir habiter
les centr-villes pour plusieurs raisons
à un certain moment donc on a ces deux
types de mouvement qui se superposent
tout en sachant que c'est le mouvement
centrifuge qui est actuellement le plus
fort donc nous avons parlé de l'exode
rural des migrations intra et
interurbaines on doit parler aussi quand
on traite des migrations intérieures des
migrations de retraité voilà vous avez
fini votre carrière vous avez un certain
pouvoir d'achat vous allez à un certain
moment vouloir quitter votre région
d'origine pour rejoint d'une région par
exemple qui est plus clémente au niveau
du climat on va donc avoir un
déplacement des personnes des régions du
centre d'un pays vers les régions qui
sont le plus au sud les régions les plus
méridionales donc vous allez observer ça
par exemple ici en Angleterre vous voyez
que les régions du sud connaissent un
accroissement de la population vous avez
l'échelle ici hein c'est le
l'accroissement de la population ici
vous voyez qu'and on est dans le bleu on
est à 9 % d'augmentation de la
population quand on est dans le clair
dans le jaune clair ou dans le beige on
est à - 15 % euh d'évolution de la
population et donc vous voyez que c'est
le cas aussi en
Allemagne ici où les
régions les plus auut Sud sont très
prisé c'est aussi le cas en France voyez
avec le notamment le longdoc Rousillon
avec la Corse qui sont des régions
vraiment euh visé par l'émigration euh
pour rechercher simplement le le soleil
c'est ça qu'on appelle l'effet
sud on aura aussi dans l'migration
intérieure la migration des fronts
pionniers donc c'est-à-dire que dans des
régions qui ne sont pas encore
occupées sur l'ensemble de leur
territoire on va avoir des des individus
qui vont aller vraiment sur la limite
euh du territoire qui est urbanisé ou
qui est habité pour acquérir de
nouvelles terres c'est ce qu'on constate
en Amazonie voyez ici vous avez
entre deux époques donc ici on est dans
les années 90 ici dans les années 2000
mais vous voyez l'apparition ici de de
de routes qui vont permettre
l'exploitation de la for amazonienne
mais qui vont faire que ensuite on va
cultiver ici on va utiliser ces terres
pour la culture et on va venir habiter
euh et donc il va y avoir vraiment un
appel un appel un appel de population
des régions intérieures vers ses fronts
pionniers
voilà c'est ce qui s'est passé
clairement au 19e siècle aux États-Unis
où durant la la ruée vers l'or ben on
avait vraiment une appropriation comme
ça des espaces libres qui étaient à
l'ouest au fur et à mesure il y av
vraiment des villes qui se
construisaient comme ça euh au fur et à
mesure évidemment les raisons de ces
migrations de Fran pionniers peuvent
être très diverses ça peut être
démographique simplement bah voilà il y
a trop de gens dans la région d'origine
donc on essaie d'avoir un peu plus plus
d'espace ça peut être économique on n'
pas de terre alors on sa on essaie
d'avoir une terre ou alors peut-être
qu'il y a des richesses hein qu' l'on
peut s'approprier comme par exemple l'or
hein aux États-Unis encore une fois ou
ça peut être des raisons stratégiques ou
géopolitiques par exemple on va avoir
euh Israël qui va sur certaines
certaines zones créer des colonies pour
vraiment coloniser en quelque sorte les
parties certaines parties de la
Palestine
alors la migration des fronts pionniers
c'est essentiellement un phénomène
intrarural puisque ce sont des des
villageois des des des ruraux des gens
des campagnes qui vont euh bouger c'est
pas des gens des villes généralement qui
quittent les villes pour aller vers les
front pionniers c'est vraiment un
déplacement de population rurale le
souci des front pionniers ben c'est que
vous quittez une région même si vous
n'avez pas de richesse qui est quand
même habitée depuis un certain temps où
il y a certaines facilités et puis vous
allez arriver dans une région où il y a
rien donc c'est assez périlleux parce
que voilà c'est des régions quand même
assez rudes exigeantes et souvent on
constate ben un abandon des front
pionniers et un retour en arrière comme
ça une
rétromigration qui s'effectue en raison
des conditions
difficiles que donnent ces fronts
pionniers alors on a certains pays où il
va y avoir vraiment une politique qui va
être mené par rapport à au front
pionnier c'est le cas de l'Indonésie
donc l'Indonésie c'est cette chipel
enfin vous ne comprenez pas les
Philippines c'est ici voilà ces îles ici
et vous avez une vraiment une asymétrie
dans le la démographie des Philippines
puisque vous voyez qu'ici au niveau de
la densité de population l'île de Java
est vraiment surpeuplée par rapport aux
autres îles euh de l'archipel donc on va
avoir ici des politiques qui vont être
mises en place pour inciter la
population à quitter cette île de Java
et à se rendre vers les espaces les
moins euh
peupé ça va être le cas aussi en Chine
où on aura des phénomènes comme la
anisation ou la sinisation euh où le
l'État va euh essayer de mettre en place
un déplacement de population des régions
les plus peuplées vers euh le zingyang
ou le
Tibet cette vidéo est ici terminée donc
n'oubliez pas de prendre quelques notes
même si on y reviendra en classe et de
compléter le quiz qui vous a proposé sur
la plateforme schogi je vous souhaite
une bonne fin de journée et à
bientôt